مع متوسط ​​الأمة لغالون
من الغاز بخمسة دولارات ، بدا الأمر وكأنه
هدية من آلهة الغاز ، لم يستطع سائق محظوظ
في رانشو كوردوفا بكاليفورنيا
تصديق عينيه
أيضًا عندما رأى 69 سنتًا للغالون
وكأنه هناك  الرقم المفقود
في المقدمة ، هذا كان في
محطة شل المحلية ، kvor ، ستيف كبير لديه
التفاصيل
69 سنتًا للغالون من محطة وقود ،
مما يمنح داريل سيريتا صفقة رائعة لم نكن نلعبها اليوم ، صرخ إلى الزميل
هنا لقد
نشر شيئًا لا يصدق  خطأ في
صفحة instagram الخاصة به ، نعم ، لقد نظرت إلى الأرقام
ورأيت أنها كانت 69 سنتًا للغالون ، لذا
فأنت تعلم ما فعلته ، لقد ضغطت على هذا
الزر وبدأت في الضخ وظلت علامة الدولار
منخفضة ، وسرعان ما خرج
أصدقاء العائلات جميعهم من الهاتف  يقول
إنه كان جنونيًا ، لقد تحولت إلى مثل
سيرك في غضون دقائق ،
بدأت أنظر حولي وكان الجميع
يبتسم مثل الجميع كان لديه ابتسامة
كبيرة وكانوا نوعًا ما مثل عدم النظر
إليك في
عينيك بطريقة ما  تم نقل النقطة العشرية في
السعر المعلن عن طريق الخطأ إلى
6.99 للغالون مقابل قسط أصبح 69
سنتًا للغالون ، لم أرَ غازًا مطلقًا بهذا
السعر في حياتي ، هل يمكنك أن تتخيل
أن مثل
هذا هو التاريخ هنا
الخطأ الذي اتخذته الإدارة في المحطة
ثلاث ساعات
لإصلاحها ، لن يعلقوا على
المجموع النهائي لخزان كامل 14
في صيف من ارتفاع أسعار الغاز
، لا يزال الناس يحاولون فهم فكرة أن
محطة الوقود هذه كانت تبيعها بشكل
منطقي ، فما الذي ستفعله بهذا؟
المال الذي وفرته
اشتر المزيد من الغاز غدًا
بمجرد نفاد